well hey guys in this video today we are
going to showcase to you 10 movie
monsters that are taken from
scandinavian and norse mythology some of
these are from the mcu and others have
been taken from other movies and maybe
one of them from a very popular series
these monsters from nordic mythology are
just awesome we have decided not to take
the monsters that are just attributed to
being nordic without having any bases in
the folklore and myths of the region we
will also not include the ones that look
like humans so
let's dive deep into this
number one fenris the first one on this
list is the giant world from the movie
thor ragnarok the one that fought the
hulk to a stalemate in asgard fenris was
a giant asgardian wolf who served heller
during the times of the expansion of
asgard throughout the nine realms
millennia after her death fenris was
resurrected by heller with the eternal
flame and put at her service during the
rule over asgard
in norse myths however fenrir with an r
is a bastard offspring of loki and was
chained up until ragnarok comes to pass
when he will break free and swallow odin
well not in a dirty manner
number two the yolo pookie on the second
spot we have the yule goat are also
called the yellow pookie and also as the
christmas goat from finnish mythology
which shows that more than christian
traditions have quite a few borings from
the northern european people it is the
main antagonist of the 2010 finnish
comedy horror film rare x-bows a
christmas tale not much of the yellow
book's body is seen but it appears to be
an enormous theater-like being with
segmented ram like horns and throughout
the film it is trapped in ice
number three the yacht nor coming from
the found footage dark fantasy movie
troll hunter the yonah are giants that
are over 200 feet tall and roam the vast
uninhabited icy lands of norway the
yotnar is a mountain troll and the
largest subspecies among trolls from
that movie reaching upwards to around
200 feet tall one yotnar appeared at the
end of the 2010 film and was killed off
the hands a character in the movie shot
it with numerous beams of uv-powered
light
yotanar or giants constitute a
supernatural tribe in scandinavian
mythology since the tribe includes fire
giants and ice guys as well they are
said to be the original inhabitants of
the world
number 4 the yorman gander and this is
the one that we said we will include
that doesn't belong to movies but from a
series called vikings and was seen in
episode 13 of season six yeoman gander
the world serpent and norse mythology is
one of three children of loki and a
giantess
the serpent was tossed into the ocean
surrounding midgard by odin where it
grew so large it eventually circled the
globe and was able to bite his own tail
in the series it was seen briefly coming
out from the ocean during a violent
storm although the show has a penchant
for nightmares and visions so the
creature might have been just a vision
and not a real monster in the viking
series
number 5 the yotens another entry from
the mcu this creature called the yodan
or frost giant is the main antagonistic
race of giant humanoids from jurgen heim
seen in the first movie of thor jordans
are a race of giants in norse mythology
a member of a race of nature spirits
with superhuman strength described as
standing in opposition to the races of
the ass and the vanner
although they frequently mingle with or
even at times were married to these in
the movie they are seen as 10 feet tall
icy beings hell-bent on killing odin and
taking over the nine realms
number 6 grendel this creature was seen
as a golden dragon in the movie beowulf
which itself was heavily inspired by the
anglo-saxon poem of the same name but it
was also deep rooted in myths of nordic
and germanic origins in the poem called
beowulf written in during the 18th
century a.d it concerns the doings of
kings and their warriors in denmark and
sweden although there is a difference in
the stories and movies in the old tales
grendel was a humanoid with super
strength and speed while in the movie he
was seen as a giant golden dragon
number seven trolls from the name itself
middle earth or in other words midgard
the lord of the rings has a heavy
influence from nordic stories and myths
and so are the creatures featured in the
six movies the trolls here in these six
flicks we have all types of trolls like
cave trolls mountain trolls half trolls
etc which are all taken or inspired from
the trolls of myths on the other hand a
troll is also a being in scandinavian
and norse mythology and in the old norse
sources beings described as trolls dwell
in isolated rocks mountains or caves and
live together in small family units
number eight the ozobot serpents this
monster which was seen in the movie
getting ragnarok or just ragnarok which
is a 2013 norwegian fantasy adventure
film about the legendary mythical story
of ragnarok
the origins of the osbox serpents
is a mystery but they are also some sort
of a giant
german gander type of being only that
they have been around at the eye of odin
a region that has since become the new
habitat after moving from the sea at
least since the viking age they are able
to outgrow other snakes and are one of
the largest beings on earth around 60
feet long and displayed proportionally
great durability sensors strength speed
and longevity
number nine motor motor is the main
antagonist of the 2017 film adaptation
of a novel also called the ritual she is
an obscure urgent that inhabits a forest
in northern sweden and is venerated by
an ancient group of cultures she was a
large elk-like creature with a body
overgrown with bland matter spikes
protruding along her spine and an
additional set of human-like hands by
her hips
her head resembles a headless human
torso with antlers for arms and arms for
legs with a vaguely human head with
glowing eyes
where its crotch would be
she was just truly terrifying to look at
and number 10
certa serra is a primordial giant
present in the norse mythologies he is
considered the one who shall end the
world during ragnarok he is also one of
two supreme evils of the old
scandinavian myths the other being loki
but in the movies he was a giant fire
demon from muspelheim that was
prophesied to destroy asgard in the
movie thor ragnarok
and he was initially defeated by thor
but when his crown was combined with the
eternal flame of asgard he came back to
life and destroyed the realm eternal
along with heller
so tell us if we have missed other
monsters from north and scandinavian
myths
i know there would be some and some of
them we haven't included because they
are just
well
how do i say it they don't look awesome
enough
and so with that we come to the end of
the video of the 10 movie monsters taken
from norse mythology and also
scandinavian and finnish myths tell us
which ones are your favorites and put in
your thoughts down in the comments
section below
so subscribe to be a part of the
minecube family hit that like button and
also smash that bell button for regular
updates on new monster content right
here on this channel and we will see you
in the next one take care fam
you